my dad told me you know never see your
skin color as as a hindrance or an
obstacle and that's why the name call
and all the other mickey mouse that
doesn't mean anything to me you know i
don't hear names i've been shot at
okay names and things don't bother me
[Music]
hey welcome to the sunday special we
have on as our special guest today
lieutenant colonel alan west he's
awesome you're going to love him we'll
get to him in just one second first
let's talk about the teeter inversion
table listen i get back pain and neck
pain sometimes
with a teeter inversion table you use
gravity in your own body weight to
decompress your spine
and relieve pressure on your discs and
surrounding nerves decompressing on a
teeter inversion table for a few minutes
today it's a great addition
to anyone's daily routine to maintain a
healthy spine and active lifestyle
without the pain
my personal trainer actually uses a
teeter inversion table all the time for
himself
if you've got back pain even if you've
been lucky enough to avoid back pain
actually you need a teeter to invert
every day and keep your back and joints
feeling really good
i feel totally better once i use the
theater inversion table it decompresses
that spine it's great for the shoulders
too i've done my homework this is the
best inversion table on the market which
is why over three million people
have put their trust in teeter they've
been the best known name in inversion
tables since 1981
and they right now are offering a
terrific deal just for my listeners for
a limited time
you can get the brand new 2019 teeter
fit spine inversion table model with a
bonus accessory
and free pair of gravity boots so you
can invert at home or take the boots
with you to the gym
teeter inversion tables have thousands
of reviews on amazon they're rated at
4.6 stars and with this deal
you'll get 150 bucks off when you go to
teeter.com
ben and you get free shipping free
return 60-day money back guarantee so no
risk to try it out
and you can only get that new 2019
teeter-fit spine inversion table plus
that free pair of gravity boots by going
to teeter.com
ben that's t-e-e-t-e-r dot com slash ben
lieutenant colonel west thanks so much
for showing up i really it's good to be
here and i need probably need one of
those uh inversion things you know for
all those jumpings out of airplanes i've
done so
let's start by let me ask you about your
military career a little bit so for
folks who don't know anything about you
you grew up in georgia in a democratic
family and then you served for 21 years
in the military
so can you kind of give your your
background your life story in a nutshell
well you know i grew up in the same
neighborhood that gave us dr martin
luther king jr it's called the old
fourth ward neighborhood in atlanta
georgia and my elementary school was
right across the street from ebenezer
baptist church
and to grow up in a family where first
of all unlike many
young black kids today i had a great
mother and father in the home my dad was
a corporal in world war
ii my mother worked with a marine corps
headquarters in atlanta georgia they
would probably tell me my hair is too
long right now
but god rest their souls and i will
never forget
at the age of 15 my dad challenged me to
be the first officer
in our family because my older brother
was a lance corporal in marine corps
doing vietnam he was wounded there
but he got out okay so my trek started
in high school junior rotc
went through rotc at the university of
tennessee got commissioned 31 july 1982
and i'd still try to live up to that
commission and that oath to support and
defend the constitution and
the great thing is that you know my
nephew now is a major in the army
following my footsteps as a paratrooper
and artillery officer
continuing that service sacrifice and
commitment that we've done in our family
well what do you think of the military
set of values that differentiate so many
folks in the military from sort of the
mainstream american population
the vast majority of whom not only have
never served i mean i never served
um you know and and thank god for folks
like you who did um but
who don't even know people who have
served what do you think differentiates
that value system
it's two things it's a service above
self and a no quit attitude
you know i always tell people they folks
ask who's your greatest military uh you
know hero and everything i'll talk about
joshua lawrence chamberlain and if you
study the battle of gettysburg
and here was a guy who's just a simple
professor of rhetoric at bowdoin college
in maine
but because he was an educated man he
got a commission he was put in charge of
a regiment the 20th main regiment
and on that second day of gettysburg
when when the ammunition is running out
casualties are mounting the 20th
alabamians still charging the hill
and they fix bayonets the first band
that charged in the union army and they
saved not just the day at gettysburg
but they probably saved this union
because if lee and the army of northern
virginia had been successful gettysburg
they would have marched on so here's
joshua lawrence chamberlain just a
simple man
a professor of rhetoric ends up being
awarded the medal of honor becomes a
governor two-time governor of the state
of maine
that's what america produces and i think
that if we can get back to that
people that believe that there's
something greater than just themselves
or a selfie or iphone or ipad or
whatever
and understand that that commitment to a
core set of principles and values like i
said i took an oath
to the constitution every one of us need
to be committed and convicted for
something that and that's why
you're such a great brilliant young man
because you know what you believe in
you know those fundamental principles
and values you've committed yourself
to making sure you pass on a better
america to your daughter and your
your your children and that's what it's
all about so
how did you move into sort of
conservative politics from from the
military so your parents
were democrats you grew up in a democrat
area obviously
what drove you toward the republican
party well see that's the amazing thing
people don't understand
uh philosophically and when you talk
about principles the black community has
always been a conservative community
it has always been about faith it's
always been about family
individual responsibility until lyndon
johnson came along with a great society
it has always been about service to the
country as i talk about four generations
out of my family
it's always been about quality education
but we don't see those things continue
to permeate now in the black community
and like i said
when johnson came along 1964-65 with his
great society programs
he eroded many of those fundamental
principles and values so
when my parents john lewis was my
congressional representative
uh growing up in atlanta and it was so
funny when i was sworn in up there and i
was a member of the congressional black
caucus
and i told him it's an honor to meet you
because you were once my representative
he was a guy he was campaigning against
me
because he didn't know my background he
didn't know i was from atlanta but if we
can get people
to think more about philosophy of
governors and not about political
parties i understand that
right and true relationship between the
individual
and the institution of government i
think we correct things and so
how my parents brought me up it was just
natural
for me to see myself as a very
conservative person
but the republican party when you talk
about it they need to understand
what their fundamental principles and
values are you talk to most republicans
been
and they don't know why the republican
party was established in 1854
it was just one issue the issue of
slavery the republican party has always
been about individual liberty
and we can talk about the history of the
other political party and it's the
complete antithesis of that
but they are able to dominate the
narrative well where do you think the
republican party has gone wrong in doing
its outreach to minority communities
because it seems like
and they were winning at the republicans
are winning a diminishing share
of the black vote diminishing share of
the hispanic vote what are they doing
wrong in reaching out is it a problem
with republicans is it a problem
with the media where do you see the
problems it's the problem with
i remember talking to reince priebus
once and i and i told him how much i
despised and detested the word outreach
because what outreach means is that you
show up in black history month or
hispanic america month or asian pacific
america month
all of these balkanized months that we
created and you act like you're a part
of the community
and then they don't hear or see you
again until 60 days before an election
when you show up and you say vote for me
what really needs to happen is policy
inclusiveness what really needs to
happen is a connection and understand
people
basically who they are and what they
believe everybody wants to be a part of
an american dream i don't believe that
people wake up every day in life and say
i want to sit here in section 8 housing
and get a check from the government but
if that's the only message that they
hear
if that's the only people that are going
into those communities and talking to
them about being
victims and not victors then the
republicans are always chasing their
tails so i think it's so important when
you look at quality education you look
at the inner cities
and how that that aspect of education is
falling apart think about this
when in 2009 barack obama canceled
the d.c school voucher program but he
sent his kids to the very prestigious
sidwell friends
but he told deserving minority kids you
can't be here
what an incredible winning issue for the
republican party
to connect when you look at as i said
when i was born in 1961 a two-parent
household in the black community
74-77 today is 24
what a great issue to talk about how we
want to restore
the sense of family and restore small
business entrepreneurship
and you you talk about urban economic
empowerment zones and all of these
things
well go in there and start showing
people what you mean by that
are republicans at a systemic
disadvantage to a certain extent with
this because
for democrats you can put democratic
oriented social workers in a lot of
these areas or you can put a welfare
office that cuss a lot of checks and
areas and this has nothing to do with
black and white actually because they're
downtrodden white communities where the
same thing is happening
but for republicans where the base the
basic message is that if we provide
you the freedom to to rise then you
should rise i mean it's your job to rise
before providing you the freedom
what should republican politicians be
doing what sort of policies would you
prefer to see
where there is that face-to-face contact
because as you say if you're only seeing
a republican once every election cycle
it's a lot less likely to vote for them
than the people who are presumably
interacting with you on a daily basis
well it was amazing a lot of people gave
president trump a lot of you know guff
about him saying
what the heck do you have to lose well
that was the true nature of
what needs to happen you know engage
with the black community say look you've
been going down the path with these guys
95 of the time what and what has it
gotten you
and so we need to challenge the status
quo and we need to have a wholehearted
effort to go into these communities
and show ourselves and show these
policies and i'm not just talking about
you know at the federal government level
i'm talking about city councils i'm
talking about school boards i'm talking
about those local representatives
that can go in there and the party needs
to support that
you know it was so funny i was talking
to uh lake highlands republicans women's
club there in dallas texas and i was
saying these exact same things
and they said that's easy for you to say
that because you're black we can't go
into a black neighborhood and say that i
said but why do white liberal
progressives
go into black and hispanic neighborhoods
and they say what they have to say
you're self-censoring yourself you're
already saying that we can't
you know have any relationship here and
i think that that's one of the horrible
things that happened
if george soros can write all these
checks and create this organization like
a black lives matter
which really is oxymoronic to me it's
just the lives that the liberal
progressive left believes that matters
in the black community
where are the benefactors on the
conservative side
they're saying we're going to get in
here and we're going to show
policy-wise what we can do and we're
going to have these connections we're
going to have
after-school programs for kids and we're
going to support the the local law
enforcement
and we're going to develop you know more
police athletic league programs support
those type of things
you got to show them something different
now how do republicans overcome the the
generalized perception the media puts
out there that they're a bunch of
racists and you see this
because there are certain situations in
which republicans say things that are
quite awful and that draws fire so for
example
in the last couple of weeks you saw what
steve king said in iowa and senator tim
scott the only black
senator came out and said the republican
party has been too easy on this sort of
stuff in the past
do you think that that's true do you
think the republican party has been too
easy on
sort of polarized or or racially tinged
or quasi-racist language in the past i
think the republican party has been
reactionary to it and not been proactive
you know we just recently had last year
the the people there in the dallas uh
city council decided to take down the
the statue of robert e lee
and i spoke there before the city
council saying
you know statues don't keep you from
going to school or
getting a job or being successful but
the left is very good at saying you know
these statues of these things these
parts of history are bad but yet
when was the last time you had anyone
talk about the founder of planned
parenthood
margaret sanger a known white
supremacist a known
a person that spoke at clan rallies and
when you look at the fact that you know
close to 70
of planned parenthood clinics are
located we're in minority communities
and so what we need to be saying is that
hey sure we don't want to deal with this
white supremacy or any but let's be very
honest
you guys have a black eye as well and
let's start calling this as it is and
when we have
these assertions you know the president
being a racist or whatever
someone needs to be on these shows cnn
msnbc whatever
and speaking out against it i cannot
tell you how many times i've been called
uncle tom sell out white man sports
monkey all of these things
for whatever reason white liberals think
that it's
open game on hispanic black female
conservatives
but yet all of a sudden they have this
you know this force field of protection
that uh you know keeps them from any
type of scrutiny we've got to break down
that force field
and what do you make of the philosophy
that's now rearing its head on campus
and
is moving in the mainstream of
intersectionality you see mainstream
democratic candidates now talking about
intersectionality
the assumption being that basically if
you're a member of particular groups
then you're inherently
victimized by american life and that
this means that we ought to take your
opinion more seriously on particular
issues of public policy
what do you make of that well then once
again that's about them creating people
to be victims and not victories there's
a great clip
i was speaking at northwestern
university last spring semester
and i was talking about the iranian
nuclear agreement and middle eastern
foreign policy i thought it did a pretty
good job for a boy you know born and
raised down south
the first question from a young black
female was
do you identify as black i mean you can
see the video clip
i mean i was just floored because i'm
thinking
out of all the things i just said that
was the only thing that you could bring
about because
there's this effort on college campuses
to say that if you're jewish
you're supposed to think a certain way
if you're black you're supposed to think
of a certain way if you're a female
whatever
and if you don't think that way you're
bad or you're confused or
you know maybe you're mentally uh
disturbed but what we want to do
no matter where you come from we need
more people to be victims why because
the left needs more people to be
dependent upon them
and the and the only people that can
have validity in the mindset of the left
are people that have been victimized
because if you
are not you know even though i was
brought up in the inner city
al sharpton jesse jackson those kind of
guys they can't you know speak for me
i don't need anyone to speak for me i
mean my wife
has a phd she was a business professor
mba
she is the daughter of people that
immigrated here from jamaica legally
her dad served 24 years in the united
states military he's buried at arlington
national cemetery
but those aren't the stories that the
other side wants to have and that's why
venues and platforms like yourself those
are the stories we should be talking
about
the stories of people that came here
legally the stories of people that
you know when they did run into hard
times they understood that maybe they
needed a safety net
but the safety net is there for you to
continue to climb to whatever
amount of success you want because the
other side wants people to just lay
around in a hammock and that's not what
america is about so in a second i want
to ask you about what role you think
racism does play in american life but
first
let's talk about a new year's resolution
you can actually keep stop going to the
post office to send letters and packages
when you don't have to save time and
money this year instead
use stamps.com stamps.com brings all the
amazing services of the us postal
service
directly to your computer stamps.com is
faster it's more convenient
it's the easier way to get postage you
simply use your computer you print
official us postage for any letter any
package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send it and the
mail carrier picks it up no more lugging
mail to the post office no more hassles
stamps.com not only saves you time it
saves you money as well with stamps.com
you get discounted postage rates you
can't even get at the post office not to
mention
it's a fraction the cost of those
expensive postage meters and there's no
equipment to lease no long-term
commitments
we use stamps.com here at the daily wire
offices because we don't feel like
schlepping down
to the post office and because we spend
an awful lot of money on our postage
right now
you too can enjoy the stamps.com service
with a special offer that includes a
four week file plus postage
and a digital scale so start the new
year off right go to stamps.com
click on that microphone at the top of
the home page type in promo code shapiro
again that's stamps.com
promo code shapiro we use it in the
shapiro household we also use it at
dailywire that's stamps.com
promo code shapiro so lieutenant colonel
west whenever i talk
about these issues with folks on the
left what they say is you are giving
short shrift the real role of
both historic and current racism in
american life you don't understand
racism and that's why you're not quick
enough to denounce racism so to take the
steve king example
steve king for years said stuff that was
very borderline and could be interpreted
a couple of different ways and i gave
him the benefit of the doubt because i
tried to give people the benefit of the
doubt then he said something in the last
couple of weeks that is just inexcusable
and there's no way for me to give him
the benefit of the doubt anymore
according to the left they would say
well why'd you give them the benefit of
the doubt in the first place if you
truly understood
how evanescent racism is how present it
is then you wouldn't be giving people
the benefit of the doubt you'd be coming
down on them when they say something
that could even be construed
as as racist how should we deal with
racism in american life how prominent
is it and what's the best way to fight
it well i think that we have seen this
resurgence of the
the word and the term racism and racist
uh
here recently because the left has used
it as a tool to get people to
self-censor
as a matter of fact we just recently had
the new freshman democrat representative
from the
state of washington representative
javapal talk about the whole thing about
this border role
is because you know donald trump wants
to keep america pure
that it's all about racism well you know
say that to
the young legal immigrant police officer
ronell singh that had nothing to do with
racism
a criminal legal immigrant killed him or
jameel shaw from right here
in uh in california or any of the other
instances where we have seen
uh kayla cuevas and then also nisa
mickens who were killed by ms-13 gang
members
so i think that what has happened is
that when the left wants to
try to get people to to shut shut down
they throw out the racist word i mean if
you disagree with barack obama you are a
racist
or if you disagree with eric holder and
and i'm tired of us you know the boy to
cry wolf
is there racism in the united states of
america of course there is
you know there are people that are going
to have inherent prejudices but the
great thing about america is that
this america now will do everything it
can to squash
and not allow those type of thoughts or
perspectives or philosophies to have any
impact or influence in our society
and i think steve king has really
relegated himself to
insignificance and irrelevance and i
would be very surprised that the people
out in
iowa were to to vote for him again i
mean because it just gets to be too much
too too often but i also think that we
need to combat
a racism that we have seen in what i
call and some people call the soft
bigotry of low
expectations you know someone could look
at a program like affirmative action
and say that's racist to say to me that
well you probably can't achieve it
so we're going to lower the standards so
you can get out there and play that was
the great thing that my dad taught me
about the military he said son when you
go into the military ain't about to
color your skin
it is all about what you can do out
there on the battlefield
and and that's how it should be i mean
and martin luther king talked about that
it's about characters not
about color to scan but for whatever
reason america has reversed and we've
gone back to talking more so about the
color of the skin issues
instead of the character people so steve
king you know this is not so much about
you know skin color it's about his lack
of character and lack of integrity
that would have him saying something as
foolish as he did so i want to ask you a
little bit about military policies one
of the things that's happened inside the
republican party
even since you left the military is a
movement away from a more hawkish
interventionist republican party and
toward
a sort of isolationist perspective now
you served in iraq
uh the prevailing opinion seems to be
not only in the mainstream media but now
inside the republican party that the war
in iraq was a horrible mistake what's
your perspective on the war
having served there and having made
policy about it in congress well i will
tell you that having been there on the
ground i mean
there were things that you gave
opportunities for for the people in iraq
that they never would have ever had you
know
folks asked me what was the greatest
achievement that you had in your 22
years
or so in the military and i would tell
you when i was in afghanistan
and seeing little girls go to school
that was the most special thing that
that i could ever think of now
the problem with our military and the
problem with the civilian leaders
that we have over the military and
political leaders they don't understand
nation building we don't need to be in
the business of nation building
there are enemies out there and when
you're dealing with islamic terrorism
we need to be denying that enemy
sanctuaries we need to be focused more
on strike operations when you look at
what is going on in syria right now
you work with you know a local allied
force like the kurds
and you provide them that support and
the resources to be able to go down
there
and do what is necessary instead of
being bogged down and worrying about
you know the syrian civil war or you
know building roads or what have you
there
and i think that that's what you know we
have lost our sight in afghanistan in
afghanistan if you're not going to do
something
about the terror sanctuaries in pakistan
then you might as well leave
because you know the two and a half
years that i was spent in afghanistan we
knew exactly what was happening
when the snows melted and the passes
opened up they came right out of
pakistan back over into afghanistan
they stayed there they fought us until
you know the snow set back in they went
back over
rearm and refit it exact same lesson we
learned in vietnam ben
laos and cambodia we were allowing the
enemy to stay stare and come in and
attack us
so you know as george santayana
attributed to him said those who fail to
learn from history are doomed to repeat
it
we need to understand and figure out
what are we going to use our military
for
our military is not there for
nation-building our military there is
as a credible deterrent force and i
think that too often people
just believe let's let's put the
military out there and let's figure out
as we go along we want define and set
goals and objectives and strategies
that enable us to achieve victory but i
tell you when i see what's happening
with iran
out there in the persian gulf and
harassment they're doing of our warships
that's got to end what what do you think
of
you know the declaration by president
trump for example that the war in iraq
was basically
lost i mean he he essentially called
george w bush a war criminal
in the middle of the campaign uh he he
suggested that people who had been
killed in in action in iraq had
basically wasted their lives
well what what do you think of you know
a republican party that's moved in this
more
very harshly isolationist direction at
least in rhetoric if not in practice
well i think it's really interesting
when people are private citizens what
they say and then all of a sudden they
sit there to resolute desks
and they get those briefings they come
to understand you know military affairs
national security and foreign policy
they take a different perspective the
united states america can't completely
withdraw from the world
we we all know that but what the united
states military and the united states
should be doing
is building those key relationships and
partnerships you look at eastern europe
you know we should be
you know better relations with poland
with the uh the baltic states latvia
estonia lithuania
what more can we do with the ukraine
because when uh vladimir putin saw us
kind of wash our hands with the ukraine
that's when he went in and he took the
crimea when he saw us decimating our
military capability capacity
he xi jinping north korea hassan rouhani
and the iranians the auditors
they saw that as the wind of opportunity
the thing is that you don't want to go
out there and seek to fight
you know every single person but you
need to have that credible deterrent
that prevents people from seeking those
aspirations
that are antithetical to liberty and
freedom all across the world if i could
have gone 22 years of my military career
been
and never had to look at my wife and my
daughters in the eyes say hey
i got to go and not know if i'm coming
back i would have been happy to do that
but it's a volunteer military and i
raised my right hand and i
understand the consequences to go to
that but all i want
are for people up in washington d.c
those elected leaders
and officials to understand if you're
going to employ the military
give us the left and right limits to be
able to go out and do what's necessary
i'll give you a case in point we sat
down with benjamin netanyahu back in
august of 2011
and he he congressional delegation he
said if you would draw all of your
troops out of iraq you're going to
create a vacuum
and something's going to fill that
vacuum that's what you need to go back
and sincerely tell president obama he
didn't listen
and look what happened and and just the
same as we
outsourced our military resources to
terrorism in libya
and look what happened so i just wish we
would think a little bit smarter and and
one of the things i believe we got to
get more veterans
more veterans that have been on the
ground and they understand the tactical
level
that can help us make the right
strategic level decisions and we got to
have those people that haven't been in
the military
they're willing to listen to them what
do you think are the proper set of rules
of engagement so obviously you came to
national notoriety originally
because of controversy over rules of
engagement in iraq i wonder if you could
tell
that story and also what you think the
the normal rules of engagement should be
for our military they seem to change
rapidly and almost randomly based on
based on headlines
well one of the things you cannot do it
should be a consistent steady state when
it comes to national security it
shouldn't be left or right
i mean that should be a constant and you
even see that in israel they can
disagree on domestic policies
but they're constant on national
security what happened with me is that
we had information about an iraqi police
officer that was feeding
uh intel over to saddam fedeen he was
not forthcoming with any information
and you know i just improvised adapted
and overcame and used a psychological
intimidation trick told him i was going
to shoot him i was going to kill him
and i actually just fired a pistol over
his head and he you know devote some
information that helped us out kept my
guys alive
but understanding i call it outside the
lines i reported myself
and about a month later you know they
came down investigated i admitted to
everything
and i think that's the most important
thing about being a leader is you you
take responsibility for your actions
and i'm here today i'm a retired army
lieutenant colonel i have all the ranks
and benefits and privileges thereof
because it was not conduct unbecoming of
an officer
everyone knew the action that i took was
to protect my men when i think of some
of the rules of engagement that you
can't fire upon the enemy until
they fire upon you two to three seconds
someone loses their life in a fire
and if we can clearly identify the enemy
we should engage them think about you
know everyone always asks questions
about ieds why are there always these
ieds around why
because some lawyers said that unless
you can prove hostile intent
a guy in the middle of the night with a
shovel with a projectile that's about
yay beard with
little cylindrical wires coming out of
it he's not showing hostile intent
and then the next thing you know in the
morning someone gets blown up so again
we cannot see it over the battlefield to
to
lawyers this is not a law enforcement
operation you don't collect someone up
and
you know question them and interrogate
them and try to charge them with
something
we got to get them off the battlefield
and i think it's so important that we
get
you know that steady state of people
that come in and understand
i don't care republican or democrat
these are young men and women that are
out there protecting our way of life
and if you're going to commit them into
an engagement then allow them to go out
there and do what needs to be done
that's why you don't hear about isis
because president trump
understood i'm going to allow the
military commanders to do what needs to
be done
so we've talked about some of the shifts
inside the republican party when you
first
came into congress you came in in 2010
with the tea party wave
and it's really interesting because now
you've seen that the republicans have
basically continued to blow out spending
despite what the tea party wave was all
about what do you think the tea party
was about because the the
the leftist take on the tea party is
that it was simply anger at president
obama
channeled toward a false end of smaller
government and then as soon as obama was
gone we didn't care about spending any
more we were happy to blow out the
spending ourselves
what do you think the tea party was and
do you think that that sentiment is
still alive well i call it
constitutional conservatism
and the tea party was all about fiscal
fiscally responsible government and
government that operated within the
parameters of the constitution
but yet when you have a republican party
that you know just
late last year they passed a 1.3
trillion dollar omnibus spending package
that's a mixed signal so again it comes
back to what we started out talking
a little bit about earlier the right
relationship between the individual
citizen and the institutional government
i think that relationship is getting
turned upside down
being a progressive has nothing to do
with r d
after your name being progressive has
everything to do with how do you see
the relationship of government to to the
individual if you think government is
preeminent then the individual is small
and you're going to tax them ad nauseum
at infinitum
to sustain that entity up in washington
dc and someone somewhere has to come
around
and reverse that cycle and and get this
government to be back what it was
intended to be and yet i hear people
talking about 70 percent
you know top tax rate 90 percent top tax
rate
what is that going to do to production
individual production
in in the united states of america so i
think that there's still a desire to
have true constitutional conservatism in
this country there's still a desire to
go back to our founding
document and our rule of law but the
thing is that do we have the people that
have the courage to go up there to
washington dc
and stand against it look the
republicans redistricted me out
in florida uh you know and and i was
always a team player
but the thing is this uh when you start
to get more attention
and and show that some people are not
standing up for what they say they're
going to stand up for
then they don't like that and so america
has to you know once again create
those those founding father type of
leaders that were visionaries
and and we're not there yet but
hopefully we can get there and one of
the things that's been really
fascinating is there's been this open
debate that's now broken out
maybe in the last couple of months
particularly uh over kind of the
direction of the republican party in
terms of what the government should do
so
it was really led off by tucker carlson
who gave this monologue on fox news in
which he suggested
that the breakdown of family structure
was due to a bunch of people in the
american economy
being left behind by economic choices
that had been made
and the counter argument was that the
breakdown of the american family and the
breakdown of a lot of our societal
institutions
was really a moral issue that started in
the 1960s was more linked to welfare
policy than it was
linked to government failures on on
tariffs and that
these problems can't necessarily be
cured by more government interventionism
that this is actually a problem of the
american soul
where do you come down on that do you
think that we have more of a moral
problem in america or do you think that
this is all just
sort of economics translated into a
moral problem people can't afford to get
married
it's a moral problem in the united
states of america and
it's it's a moral messaging problem
where
you know people have devalued family to
the
i mean they devalued life i mean you
think about since roe v
wade almost 18 million black babies have
been murdered in the womb
and that's something that should be
unconscionable people you want to talk
about genocide
and so again when i look at the
breakdown in the black community of the
family
and the fact that you had a government
program that said we're going to give
a woman a check from the government if
she has her child out of wedlock
continue to give her a check
but the caveat is that she can't have a
man in the home
so the the the maybe unintended but i
think somewhat intended consequence is
that
you remove the responsibility of the man
in the home
in a community where the man had always
been that
that responsible figure i mean what got
the black community through slavery
segregation jim crow all of these things
it was that solid black family it was
that sense of community
and now that's been decimated so do i
think that another government program is
going to repair that no i think that
there has to be awakening within each
and every one of us
to say that we can do better than that i
mean we can protect our unborn
we can restore our families but until we
get
you know the hollywood and the culture
back on track that's going to be an
uphill battle in a second i want to talk
to you
about texas because your book is whole
texas hold the nation we'll talk to you
about that in one second first
let's talk about your impending death
well hopefully not that impending
hopefully it's a long time before you
die but when you do plots
you're going to wish that you had life
insurance and at least your family is
going to wish that because
you don't want to be buried in a
pauper's grave you don't want to leave
your family without any options
but getting life insurance is kind of
intimidating there are a lot of options
it's hard to know where to start
making sure your family is financially
protected it's too important to avoid so
policy genius created a website
that makes it easy for you to compare
quotes get advice and get covered
without extra fees or commissioned sales
agents policy genius is the easy way to
get life insurance in minutes you can
compare quotes from top
insurers to find the coverage you need
at a price you can afford from there you
can apply online
and the advisors at policy genius will
handle all the red tape for you they'll
even negotiate your rate with the
insurance company
all part of their best price guarantee
and policy genius doesn't just make life
insurance easy
whether you're shopping for disability
insurance or homeowners insurance or
auto insurance they can help you get
covered fast if you've been intimidated
or frustrated by insurance in the past
you're not alone
but try starting your search at
policygenius.com in minutes you can
compare quotes and apply you can do the
whole thing on your phone right now in
fact do it pull over
take your phone now go to policy genius
and give them a try it's the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance go check
them out right now at policygenius.com
it is the responsible thing to do it's
what's going to ensure that your family
is okay if god forbid something
happens to you go check them out right
now policygenius.com
okay lieutenant colonel west you have a
new book out it's called hold texas hold
the nation
so what's the what's the basic premise
why is texas the key to the nation
because the two biggest electoral uh
vote states
california and texas and the left
without a doubt have their sights on
texas as a matter of fact their mantra
is turned texas blue
and if you followed the election results
from this past november
they were desti they really were close
to it as a matter of fact i live in
dallas dallas county woke up
my congressional representative was gone
state house
state senate a lot of the judicial
appointees gone
and what is happening is that the
greatest export that comes out of
california is not avocados wine or
walnuts
it's progressive socialism and if you
look at what nevada used to be you look
at arizona you look at colorado you look
at new mexico
and for whatever reason people are
leaving california
because of the failed tax and regulatory
policies but they're migrating to states
they used to be red states
and they're flipping them because
they're you know once again
holding on to these same failed policies
so even though
texas with the incredible economic
vibrancy and the economic
opportunities you have there all the
right tax and regulatory policies
all the businesses and corporations that
are moving there texas
almost elected a far left progressive
socialist as a senator
came within three points of winning how
does that happen
because when you look at these major
population centers the dallas the austin
the san antonio the houston el paso
it's all trending toward the blue
and even though texas has 254 counties
if all of that population centers in the
i-35
corridor and some other places it's just
a matter of time
and if the left is successful and turn
in texas
the national level elections are done
you're never going to be able to reverse
that cycle well one of the scariest
things that i saw about the pulling from
texas in the aftermath of cruz's narrow
win over
bob o'rourke is he called yeah it was is
that
the the polls tended to show that
immigrants from other parts of the
country actually tended to vote for cruz
that it was homegrown texans young
homegrown texans
who are voting actually more and more in
favor of democrats
why do you think that's happening well
that's the young people and of course
when you go to like a place like the
university of texas and of course
representative o'rourke was at his event
skateboarding and what have you
but you're also seeing a lot of people
that are coming into texas the
the heads of these corporations
understand why they're moving
but yet they're not talking to a lot of
the employees now without a doubt there
are people that are coming from
california illinois and new york and new
jersey i've had it
with the policies there especially the
tax policies but you also are having
people that are coming in
within the last year or two years they
don't know the the history of texas
but yet they're able to immediately come
in and vote and i think it's so
important that
it's almost like a proactive uh
marketing
venture that texas has to go into to say
you know welcome to texas but why are
you here
and they also have to talk to those
young people those future generations
to say you know what future do you want
to have a future of liberty i mean you
think
think about this ben um last september
they had to have a special
uh session for the texas state board of
education because someone came up with
the idea of removing
the word uh heroic in reference to the
defenders of the alamo
and texas history books now how does
that happen
and and their people in austin want to
change the name but the capital of the
city of texas
because he wants owned slaves and so i
think it is yes
young people but i think that there's
also a demographic that is coming in
and you've seen that happen like i say
in nevada in arizona
in colorado and the politics in colorado
dictated
denver and boulder pretty much and also
new mexico where
albuquerque and santa fe dictate the
politics and think about what is
happening on the other side of the
mississippi river
where it used to be you know a very red
state virginia
the state that gave us millions of our
brilliant founding fathers
now all because of one county basically
fairfax county right across the river
from washington d.c
it dictates the policies i mean they
have not had a statewide
republican victory in virginia for i
think going on now
nine years well what exactly should
republicans be doing
differently in in texas per se
especially because when you look at
texas it's interesting i had
governor greg abbott on my show a little
while ago and he has been winning a
pretty significant percentage of the
hispanic vote if you look at how
california has moved in terms of the
hispanic vote
versus texas it's really quite stunning
the hispanic vote in california goes
70 30 democrat and in texas it goes like
55 45 democrat it's a lot closer between
democrats and republicans what do you
think that texas republicans have been
doing the california republicans have
not in terms of hispanics
i think that the difference is that many
of the hispanics that are coming into
california are coming
you know centered around an illegal
immigrant philosophy
where many of the hispanics that are
coming into texas there have been some
studies about this
more about the small business
entrepreneurship they still have those
basic conservative values about family
they want better education opportunities
and so they understand that connection
with the uh with the republican party i
mean hispanic
uh programs in texas are very strong
and and i think you see that reflect and
then of course you know governor abbott
has a hispanic uh wife who without a
doubt being the first lady of texas
i mean she's a great person to go out
and deliver that message
and but i think that overall not just in
texas but everywhere
republicans have to get back into the
major population centers
they wrote them off for so long and now
that's where the left
is bringing everyone into and those
policies
in most of those urban areas are failing
even in red states they're failing
you know again in georgia when stacey
abrams won she had the atlanta
metropolitan area then all the rest
around it was red
but she came within what two points of
winning so i think that's where someone
in the republican party
needs to sit back and look at the big
map and say how do we start
penetrating you know quote unquote the
the blue wall in these
you know major population centers i
heard one person uh
say that you know pennsylvania you've
got
pittsburgh on one side and philadelphia
on the other side and in between is
alabama
okay so so how do we start figuring out
getting that message into philadelphia
and pittsburgh think about i mean
the sugar tax the soda tax in
philadelphia who does that hurt the most
the people in those inner city areas
illegal immigration the sanctuary of
city policies who does that hurt mostly
the minority population is there look at
what is happening
in the south side of chicago with the
rampant gang violence
that's where we need to be and and if we
don't
take that seriously i mean it's just a
matter of time and that's
why i'm fairly pessimistic about 2020. i
don't get your thoughts on this because
in 2018
the republicans showed up i mean they
showed up to vote and then they got
swamped
basically all the red areas got redder
all the blue areas got bluer and all the
purple areas got very blue yes
very quickly all those suburban areas
got very blue and
if republicans keep doubling down on
this narrow base
they're going to lose i mean president
trump i think that a lot of republicans
have
have fallen into the trap of thing that
because trump pulled a rabbit out of the
hat in 2016 by
winning 80 000 votes in the correct
three states while losing the popular
vote by 3 million
that that's replicable and i'm having a
hard time seeing exactly how
that's replicable over the long haul or
even over the over the short term
no you're absolutely right and i think
and you and i have this discussion also
is that the american people are very
visual and you can have all the right
policies and everything like that
but you know president trump has to
understand that there is an
optic and his personality can turn
a lot of people off and that's why you
have seen a lot of republicans and we
had that happen
in the state of texas where you had the
uh the uh you could break up your
your you don't have the straight line
ticket voting right and there were a lot
of people that were picking and choosing
in there and so what we need to do is
have someone that is that standard
bearer
that does portray that leadership image
and the policies relate back to it
because the left is going to go back
into those places where he
thought that he would have that success
again i mean look at wisconsin
i mean we were not successful in
wisconsin in 2018
this last election cycle and so i think
that they're going to do everything they
can
to not allow that to be replicated in
2020.
so what exactly should republicans do
because it seems like president trump
isn't changing his stripes anytime soon
i think republicans have to talk about
you know the economy
they have to talk about and they have to
do this in the inner cities they have to
talk about
how they can make things better school
choice school vouchers education
those are better things for the
republicans to talk about in the inner
cities
i think that once again we need to talk
about you know americans are safer we
haven't had these you know flurry of
terrorist attacks
like we did in the eight years of the
obama administration i'm sure a lot of
people here still remember what happened
to san bernardino
back a few years ago in december so
those are the type of things we have to
really talk about but again
it cannot be this outreach thing it has
to find those policies
that bring people to understanding that
right relationship between themselves
and the institution of government the
fact that
this should be playing over and over and
over when the president last stated
union address announced that black
unemployment was
at an historic all-time low and they
panned over to the members of the
congressional black caucus
and they just sat there stoically those
are the type of images you need to show
to the american people if you really
want to win
on this illegal immigration debate and
the thing about the wall get the angel
moms out there get the people that have
been victimized
by illegal immigration what i would say
is president trump you're doing great
things less of you on camera
okay and let let these stories tell
themselves
and let the american people tell some of
these stories instead of you trying to
do it so
lieutenant colonel west you were in
congress for a couple of years do you
have any
intent to go back into politics are you
enjoying yourself too much well
i tell you ben i have a heart of service
to this country and my arm has been
broken so much about you know running
again i don't try to reset it anymore
so uh that was a topic of discussion
with my wife and my two daughters
uh over the holiday period my oldest
daughter is about to graduate from
physician assistant school and
my youngest daughter will graduate
college this summer so
uh that frees angela and i up to you
know
consider some other things that'll
definitely be interesting well i wanted
to get your take also on some of the
issues
culturally that seems to have cropped up
um we've talked about racism already but
the other one that has cropped up is
what seems to be sort of a war on
masculinity now
you you seem to you seem to be a pretty
good
uh example of traditional masculinity in
american life obviously a military man a
couple of kids
uh what do you make of the the war on
what they call toxic masculinity yeah
i i think it's absolutely absurd and you
know this gillette ad that they came out
i don't use gillette products well i'll
just get that out there but
you know the left is defining everything
they're defining now what masculinity is
you know masculinity is about a person
that is a man that understands his
responsibilities
and as a protector but yet all of a
sudden being a guy
is is associated with all things that
are bad and
i just hate this collective you know
perspective
and and this group think perspective
that lumps everybody
in so i think it's very important that
we
redefine you know what the the roles are
for men in our society
look i have two daughters and anyone
that tries to you know harass
you know my two daughters or whatever
they're gonna have to they'll find their
way to me
and that's an important thing about
being a strong male
role model and the father figure and the
exact same thing with you and your kids
but when we continue to have this chip
chip away when when you have
colin kaepernick and that nike uh
commercial you know
believe in something even if it means
sacrificing everything
the perfect person that nike should have
used was pat tillman
here's a pro football player after 9 11
said
there's something better than this and
unfortunately lost his life but
enlisted into the army as an infantryman
as a ranger and gets deployed to
afghanistan
so i think that what we need to do is
start to fight that cultural war
and stop allowing the left to define
everything they define what it means to
be jewish and what it means to be black
what it means to be hispanic what it
means
to be a woman what it means to be a man
masculinity and everything we got to
stop this
so you sat in congress for a couple of
years you saw how unworkable it is
obviously there are a lot of folks right
now
who are deeply disturbed by the
unworkability of congress and a lot of
republicans who are frustrated i'm one
of them
republicans controlled the house of
representatives for years they
controlled the senate for years they
finally get the presidency
and for two years they basically pass a
tax cut they barely pass a repeal of the
individual mandate and nothing else they
don't defund planned parenthood they
don't build the wall
they don't they they do a little bit of
regulatory rollback but they don't
restructure welfare in any significant
way
how can congress operate better than
this does is is it
should it be more partisan and more
pedal to the metal or should be people
be looking for some sort of compromise
with democrats i think it comes back to
us as the american people
and what we want in our elected
officials and representatives
uh because you know we're the ones
voting and putting them
in those positions and again i think the
term limits is so important
i think too often people get up there
and they just get linked into the d.c
way of doing things and
they don't want to change they really
believe that the center of power in the
united states of america is in
washington dc even more so on capitol
hill
they don't put the interest of the
american people above
special interests or their own
self-interest
and that's a bipartisan thing without a
doubt so that you're right here you have
people say
give us the house and we'll do this
where you get the house well you know
now we need the senate okay here's the
senate well you know if we could just
have the white house
and then they get all three and then
they fail one of the things that i
admire
about the the left and the democratic
party they're tenacious
even in the minority they're tenacious
because they're true believers
in what they believe in even if it's
wrong but for
us we don't show that we're true
believers and i think at some point
in time we have to have those elected
representatives in the republican party
that are true believers and and i don't
know if we're going to get there within
the next
you know four years but this is my real
vision that i think will happen there
will be a third party
that will rise in the united states of
america that will say you two party guys
you failed us you're not getting
anything done you you hunker down
in these respective holes and you're not
taking care of us
and if someone can come along and show a
principled vision for this
this country you you'll find a third
party do you think that that's more
plausible or the plausibility is that
somebody's going to come up inside one
of the parties so
this has been the case made about
president trump is that he tried in 2000
to run on a third-party ticket basically
with the reform party then decided not
to
uh we've seen third parties before try
and fail in american life and then trump
launches this outsider campaign and
basically takes over the party
bernie sanders launched an outsider
campaign inside the democratic party
basically took over that party
do you think it's more plausible that
there will be a rising third party or
that there will be a force inside one of
these parties that just
well i think i think that there will be
a movement amongst the people
i really do and somehow the people will
find someone to to elevate i mean
you know i often go back and always talk
about how the you know the
the children of israel said they want a
king god said okay
here you go here's saul and the next
thing i was like oh no no no
no and even when you know uh
samuel went to the house of jesse and he
saw all of those sons and he thought it
was this
son he thought it was that son and god
said no it's that that kid there it's
the little scrappy kid coming in from
tending to sheep that's gonna be the one
so i think somewhere there's a david out
there that's out there just
tending the sheep you know minding his
own business
but he will be the one that will take
this country to his next level and
restore this country
as a constitutional republic and and
then our education system
has to educate people about what it
means to be we're not teaching our
constitution we're not teaching our
founding documents we're not teaching
our history
and so something has to happen that that
revolution has to happen
because we have a system of
indoctrination now a system of education
and i think when all those things align
themselves
we have the right so are you optimistic
or pessimistic about the future i'm
always optimistic man because if
if you're pessimistic why wake up you
know it really is and
and i did not four generations in my
family
all combat uh veterans we didn't fight
for america to to look like a venezuela
when i was a young lieutenant and i went
through checkpoint charlie
over east berlin i knew exactly the
reason why
there was a united states of america do
you think that um there should be some
sort of national service component
because obviously being in the military
changed you obviously it had a long line
in your family
of changing people there's been a lot of
talk about the idea that young people
particularly don't feel
any sense of solidarity with the with
the ideals of the united states we feel
increasingly disconnected because of
social media and isolated do you think
that there should be consideration of a
national service like they have in
israel for example some type of national
service not exactly bringing back a
military draft
because as a former commander i don't
need to spend 95 of my time with
you know five percent that don't want to
be there it should be a privilege
to wear the uniform in the united states
of america and serve this country in
uniform
but there's so many other things the
forestry service i mean just being
in some of these local communities and
around here going to
uh some of the uh you know feed the
homeless type of places that's the type
of community service
to let these kids know that life does
not you know center around you taking a
selfie and your ipad and your iphone
there's something greater remember we
talked about
what separates the military from the
rest of the civilian society
service above self and we got to restore
that in these future generations
so you've been going around a lot with
the young americans foundation obviously
they're a group that
i work with as well and you've been
going to a lot of college campuses
what's made you
optimistic and what's made you
pessimistic what was the worst question
you got uh
while you're on the road and uh and you
know you've seen some protests as well
what's that been like going to these
well the worst
the worst question was when the young
lady at northwestern university asked me
if i identified it
as black and but that also gave me a
window in the understanding that that
level
of indoctrination is happening that
people are just believing that
you have to it's called the borg and the
old star trek next generation that
you know you will assimilate resistance
is futile you you don't have an identity
you're just six or seven or seven or
nine or whatever
and and so that's very troubling for me
because
college is supposed to be a place where
you develop critical thinking skills
and you're supposed to have that
intellectual debate and you're not
having that
and i've been to places where you know
folks you know they hold up the signs
trying to disrupt you or whatever and
you just plow right through it
and what keeps me optimistic is that
when you go on these campuses ben and
you see
those young future conservatives that
are standing up in the most horrific of
situations i mean
i don't know if i could have done that
if if i was a college student in in
these same uh
areas where you know your professors are
against you the administration's against
you your peers are against you
and they continue to stand so the least
i can do
is to be optimistic and to fight for an
america to give these young deserving
people
how about the case that that colleges
are basically trashed i mean this is a
case that's been made by some
conservatives
which is that the best move for for
conservatives would be to take their
kids and either put them
in places like hillsdale college yeah or
to or to take their kids
out of college completely and do the
peter thiel thing just if they've got
money give them their kids money
get them an apprenticeship and find a
way for them to avoid college do you
think that college is actually a useful
bargain for a lot of people no i think
college is still useful i think that you
know to develop
the the mind is a very important thing
but i think that we should have a
hillsdale college in every single
state in the united states of america uh
northwood university is another school
up in michigan
that's a free market for enterprise
institution we should have one of those
you know i once went to some very
wealthy uh white
philanthropist and i said look at how
historic black colleges and universities
are struggling
wouldn't it be great if you went in and
just bought a few of them
and turned them into constitutional
conservative
black institutions you know because when
you read you know booker t washington's
you know autobiography
up from slavery how did he establish
tuskegee institute he established
tuskegee institute based upon
conservative principles uh education
entrepreneurship and self-reliance
now that's what we should be you know
bringing forth in
in all of our schools that you're there
to get a relevant education
not just there to get some education in
women's studies or underwater basket
weaving
and then you got to go out and be a
barista at the starbucks and you got all
kind of massive debt
what are we doing to to develop the next
generation of productive americans to go
out into our society and that's why i
mean we've got to rethink
how education is done sure not every kid
needs to go to college
but college needs to be there needs to
be available but it needs to be relevant
education well this does raise the
question of conservative donors because
it seems like conservative donors very
often they only want to give to a couple
of causes when they want to give to
their church
do they want to give to a political
candidate or three they want to give to
somebody who they think is making a
splash how do we change minds in the in
the conservative giving community to say
look
you actually have to invest in local
institutions that may not
put your name on a building and that may
not actually you know benefit you in the
in the press
again they got to stop thinking about
themselves and stop you know creating
these
organizations that is reflective of them
in their own little rice bowl or their
own little silo
i mean when i look at you know the
george soros's and the tom steyers
and michael bloomberg i mean they find a
cause
and they fund that cause from the
strategic level down to the tactical
level
and you you can walk it back to all of
these groups that are out there moms
demand action uh
the environmental groups the uh the
black lives matter antifa whatever
and you can trace it back to one of
these top funders
but we don't have that same type of
fervor i mean we've got the resources on
our side
to go out there and buy newspaper and
why aren't we doing that
and then we sit back and we wring our
hands and say oh you know they control
this and they control that they control
it because we are seeding that territory
over to them
so i am looking yeah we do need people
that think from
at the strategic level say i'm going to
you know develop my army that can get
down here
at the tactical level on the ground they
can get in this neighborhood
in eck city and i'm going to replicate
that in other
neighborhoods and in cities all across
you know i'm going to you know take on
this mantle of
building constitutional conservative
centers of uh higher education
and and that's going to be my my cause
but instead we just got guys that you
know throw a little bit here through a
little bit there
and they don't fight like the old greeks
remember all greece used to lock their
shields and create the phalanx
we don't fight like that on the con
constitutional conservative side and
it's really easy
for us to get picked off well colonel
west i want to ask you
about what what drives you because
obviously you're driven by a sense of
mission and purpose what instilled that
in you
when you were young or what what gets
you up in the morning every day i mean
because
you're are you a person of religious
faith where does that come from oh
absolutely i mean you know every guy
born down south got a little bit of you
know pastor in him
but my dad and my mom were just
incredible
and you know my dad when he told me that
you know there's no greater honor than
wearing a uniform in the united states
of america
and here was a man born in 1920 my mom
was born in 1931 down south
those weren't exactly good times to be
you know black
in the united states of america but they
never had a disparaging word about this
country
they always believed that the
opportunities were there for me
to go and excel and do whatever i wanted
to do in this great nation
and and that's what i fight for i i call
it the difference between
the equality of opportunity and the
equality of outcomes
my dad told me you know never see your
skin color as a hindrance or an obstacle
you know you find out what the standard
is what it what it means to get the a
and then you get an a plus
and that's what what i'm driven to do
and the other thing is that you got to
be driven to make sure that
the the generations coming behind you
have it better than what you had
and and that's why i get up every day
and that's why the name call and all the
other mickey mouse that doesn't mean
anything to me
you know if you're not willing to sit
down and have that intellectual debate
then i'm just you know you're irrelevant
you know i don't hear names i've been
shot at
okay names and things don't bother me
you know and and and i think that's
another thing
that on our side we got to realize
forget about the name calling
if you stay focused on that goal and
objective if you know
what what your end state is then you're
going to get there
and and you're just not the the noise
it's just background noise
so colonel west i have one final
question for i want to ask you what
advice you would give to
a 16 year old kid in the united states
right now who feels like opportunities
kind of slipping away whatever community
they're in what would you say to them to
inspire them to to greatness
and i'm going to ask you that question
in just one second but first if you want
to hear colonel west's answer you
actually have to be a daily wire
subscriber right that's how we get you
to pay
to subscribe go over to dailywire.com
click subscribe you can hear the end of
our conversation there
the lieutenant colonel was thank you so
much for stopping by everybody should go
pick up a copy of hold texas hold the
nation
colonel west it really is an honor and a
pleasure to have you mark pleasure ben
thank you
the ben shapiro show sunday special is
produced by jonathan haye executive
producer jeremy boring associate
producer mathis glover
edited by donovan fowler audio is mixed
by dylan case hair and makeup is by
jesua olvera
title graphics by cynthia angulo the ben
shapiro show sunday special is a daily
wire production
copyright daily wire 2019.